junot want to see wire no queremos más
promesas solamente queremos las vacunas
juli vaccinated este es el enésimo
llamado del presidente de la
organización mundial de la salud para
que los países ricos dejen de
administrar dosis de refuerzo contra el
hobbit 19 a sus poblaciones mientras
muchos países pobres prácticamente no
tienen acceso a las vacunas un llamado
que asegura ha caído en oídos sordos
five point find boxing
western se han administrado 5500
millones de dosis de vacunas pero el 80%
se ha administrado en países de nivel
medio alto y alto el objetivo mundial de
la oms ese sigue siendo ayudar a todos
los países a vacunar al menos al 10% de
su población a finales de este mes
'la es fortí persona al menos al 40 por
ciento a finales de año y al 70% de la
población mundial a mediados del próximo
año casi el 70% de los países ricos han
vacunado completamente al 40% de sus
habitantes pero ninguno de los países
pobres ha logrado vacunar siquiera al
10% de su población y esto holding
autismo
de estos materiales que vimos al
principio de la pandemia pero no sólo es
injusto no sólo es inmoral sino que está
prolongando la pandemia y está
provocando muertes tenemos suficientes
vacunas en todo el mundo si hubiéramos
utilizado las dosis de vacunas
disponibles de otra manera estaríamos en
una situación muy diferente ahora mismo
que fermín a
la organización pidió una moratoria de
terceras dosis al menos hasta finales de
este año y recordó a los países ricos
que de los 1.500 millones de vacunas que
se han comprometido a donar a otras
naciones menos del 15% ha llegado a su
destino